you and I seem to have a similar
relationship with running I like this
idea of a slow treadmill I like running
slow yeah
you know like a 10 minute mile or
something like this so I'll just run
forever just listen to an audiobook
listen to Brown noise think I love it
what's brown noise it's actually
Brownian noise
um but short brown noise it's kind of
like white noise but deeper so it's just
noise like
that oh wow it kind of sounds like a
waterfall and I'll just listen to it and
something happens to them I think
there's you can ask Superman about this
I don't but apparently there's some
science it kind of focuses the mind and
so on
it's funny because I think sometimes
when people don't get about running is
they go they get on and they put it on
like a six right away on like a
treadmill and they go I can't do this
for [__] 30 minutes but you can if
you build yourself up to your six
and you play games I play games with
myself a lot like I'll play games where
I go
um and I I can do this I can do this I
can do this almost not all day long but
I can do this a lot longer like I did it
for two hours the other day before my
workout or no hour and a half before my
workout where I started at 3.5 walking
and then I and then I get my jog up to
like a five and then I'm like 5.5 then I
go six and then I go and once I'm in a
six my body's really loose and so then
I'll go all right bring it down to a 3.5
and then I go punch it to a 7.5 for a
quarter of a mile and then let's walk at
a four let's jog in a five night I can
do that I love they're called uh
fartlets I think and I love those like
where it's like it's
regimented running and sprinting at
certain levels I love that and I love
also when I work out to listen to music
but put on foreign language cooking
shows on Netflix
can you explain that they just put it on
mute you don't need to hear it for some
reason they're sexier the way they're
shot they're sexier yeah and it's like
street food Asia and they're just
watching them make street food in Asia
there's one called broth it's called
broth the nation of broth and they're
just making broths and you're like [__]
I want some broth so this is South
America this is Asia South America Asia
um they do one on pizzas I've watched
this one on pizzas that I've watched it
there's like four episodes I've watched
every episode so many times that my
trainer goes God that's that [__] I
could watch that again yeah
um I love watching foreign language
cooking shows on mute when I work out
while blasting music while Boston helps
you Darren
all right well I usually run outside but
I do oh I can't think I don't mind
hiking and I like I do like you know
what my fun thing the fun thing I would
do and this is a this is ripped off
totally from cam Hanes is I like to go
uh there's a great hike called Fryman
Canyon out in the valley where I live
and I'd be like all right I'm gonna run
to primary Canyon I'm gonna jog the
farming Canyon I'm gonna hike farming
Canyon and then I'm gonna jog back
and I wonder how long that is I go don't
think about it just know that that's
your thing just know that that's your
thing and then all of a sudden you're
like [__] that was eight miles you're
like that's a [__] beast the hike
doesn't even feel like anything the
height once you do the jogs the hard
part there the jog home is a [__]
Cakewalk I had the best jog when I was
in Serbia I had the best jog I think it
was in Hyde Park I think the name of the
Park's Hyde Park
it was get this it was 80 downhill wow
so this jog you started the park and it
was like and I'll do it like this for
you you went like downhill like this
downhill like this downhill like this
and then it was like a little steep
incline to get to the beginning of it so
it was like a little like nice like
lower back pain you're like okay okay
and then the jog was perfect and use it
four times it was four miles I loved it
my very first day I did it a butterfly
got in front of me it's like six in the
morning yeah six in the morning and a
butterfly got in front of me and it ran
the whole first Mile in front of me and
I just it was like so surreal it would
disappear and then it would show back up
in front of me you sure it was real no
definitely real and then the next day
and so I go I'm on the right path I'm on
the right path the next day I go for a
jog six in the morning and it rained and
as I'm doing this deep uphill incline a
tree collapsed in front of me just went
and I went whoa a tree fell in the woods
and I was here to see it shut the [__]
up I was like that's crazy and it didn't
hit me like I'm on the right path and
then I started getting overthinking it
like the next day I saw a condom and I
was like this is a good place to join I
was like people [__] here last night
but but yeah that was one of the best
jobs I've ever had I could do that I
could run that Park every single day and
no one jogged that Park in Serbia I
actually recently had a condom on my
doorstep and I I wanted to ask whoever
is up there above what what that means
what the
you know what the story behind that is
yeah because I you know just a pissed
off UPS guy I I just was it compromised
what do you mean compromised like was
there stuff inside it oh I didn't look I
mean very few people put on the economy
oh it's not for me I'm gonna take it off
yeah it's a little tight it could be to
send a message like a horse's head kind
of thing oh yeah I don't know I don't
know what the message is exactly do you
use condoms if you had a one-night stand
would you use a condom I don't know what
a condom is I didn't never heard it I'm
learning good call I'm learning I've
learned about sex from you today if my
wife dies there's no condoms in my
future I'll get it I don't care I have
babies I don't give a [__]
your Mana principle I like it